alors oui ma part ce que met pas un
point commun ce que l'état on va faire
une interview première fois alors
attention ça commence simplement premier
choc premier choc
ah oui ça c'est quand comme mon papa
était parti de chez nous vous deviez 12
ans 6 12 ans que vous apprenez plus aux
parents avaient divorcé au fait parce
que ma maman elle comptait la mare hier
quant à la couse n en perd elle était
encore très jeune et puis ça va pas
vraiment si elle était amoureuse ou pas
à l'époque elle est tombée enceinte et
puis c'était obligé qu'est-ce qu'elle se
marie et quand j'avais 3 ans elle a
trouvé un autre en main c'est à tomber
amoureuse il ya il ya 70 ans
je pense à cette femme qui qui qui qui
d'un coup tombe sur un autre homme qui
lui convient mieux et c'est la vie je
sais moi je termine en divorce
c'est terrible ça c'est arrivé parce que
ça c'est bien alors donc effectivement
commis le péché qu'est ce qu'il se
passait quelque chose de mal qu'on a
fait voilà oui c'est quand j'ai par là
là c'est quand je suis parti partie de
la maison pendant trois jours un an mais
ne savait pas où j'étais et en fait je
suis parti avec les amis à moi on était
plusieurs secondes et c'était un garçon
et défis et on est parti on savait même
pas où
dans une maison faite le garçon il nous
a dit j'ai les clès et une maison à la
campagne c'est très sympa et tout et on
est allé on est parti de la maison et à
la fin s'est rendu compte qu'il avait
pas de créer en fait on est rentré
dedans un peu en force est assez 80 mais
c'est en république tchèque le premier
coup de foudre j'ai 14 ans je suis
tombée amoureuse vraiment d'un
photographe non pas du tout d'après vous
les cibles de moi n'ont jamais je pense
non parce que les mannequins parts échec
des photographes le soir et nuit tombe
très tôt aux seychelles non tu n'es pas
une fille banale bien attention à ces
tapoter à l'appontage il va attention on
se concentre arrêt un village et ovi
chat faisait longtemps que je me la joue
attention nous attendait là c'est très
important
on se concentre irène premier baiser sur
la bouche sur la langue propre a
sagement à papa à 6 ici comme des
données lors la première fois non mais
c'est un oui c'était c'est un garçon que
j'ai que refuge et or en sort ensemble à
l'école et puis il arrive et me lance un
bisou sur la bouche et il part tout de
suite et c'est peu après je me suis dit
quand c'était lui c'était marrant et
avec la langue c'est vous en sommet je
me souviens que j'avais 13 ans à 59
il avait 15 ans alors et alors il foule
est en fait beaucoup mais moi je vous
mets pas à l'époque
et comme chez d'embrasser je suis très
pas ça ça me fout et après je me suis
brosser les dents pendant cinq minutes
c'est de là que j'ai décidé de fumer au
beaucoup plus tard que moi là alors
première fois il va vous êtes retrouvé
toute nue avec un garçon un peu un peu
bête comme ça un peu bête comme ça oui
je crois que c'était en vacances avec
avec mes parents quand j'étais en
espagne il savait rien moi j'ai
rencontré ces garçons et un de vos
commentaires après oui après on est
parti sur la plage et puis on a c'est un
peu des trucs mais ça n'a pas marché ça
va pas marcher
ils auront la première fois qu'il ait
retrouvé nu avec un gars en avant qui
rate à marquer
à eelv on arrive aux choses sérieuses
double tapotage première fois pour de
vrai avec un garçon vraiment c'était
joli 16 ans c'est une saison c'est avec
cette cette personne que j'aimais
c'était le premier coup de foudre et on
a attendu longtemps mais financier
attendu deux ans oui oui ça s'est bien
passé
oui très bien bien première fois à 3
qu'on ait fatras bas voire premiers pas
de trois sets c'était et ah ouais j'ai
eu
j'ai eu 17 ans ça s'est bien passé il
très bien première fois avec un
animateur télé
si jamais bamako animateurs